hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his homily number 14 on Paul's letter
to the Ephesians John chrysostom is
going to discuss a number of for him
interrelated matters namely the emotion
of anger our tendency to fall into sin
because of it the factor of time and the
devil the adversary for not only God but
also for us human beings you could say
the prime troublemaker and instigator
who wants us to be angry and to stay
angry and for that anger to develop into
enmity or hatred and he's going to be
explaining and citing several verses
coming from this letter one right after
the other that chrysostom takes as being
sort of interconnected with each other
the first probably everybody has heard
of if you've looked in into Christian
literature about anger be angry and sin
not meaning that you know anger by
itself is not the automatically bad
thing it could have some legitimate uses
but don't don't fall into sin because of
it the second one you may have
encountered you know in a more uh
contemporary form don't go to bed angry
right let not the sun go down on your
wrath as how Paul talks about it and
then the third one neither give place to
the devil don't let the devil get in
there because once the devil does you're
going to have greater problems than you
started with and so chrysostom Begins by
talking about this verse be angry and
sin not he says observe his wisdom whose
wisdom Paul's he both speaks to prevent
our sinning and if we do not listen
still does not forsake us for his
fatherly compassion does not desert us
and he gives the example of a physician
a doctor right what does your doctor do
well in the old days they didn't spend a
lot of time with paperwork or insurance
or things like that they instead would
you know observe you diagnose you give
you a prescription and interestingly you
notice the prescription here is not go
and take some drugs that's just like one
possible thing in ancient medicine you
per you might have prescribed drugs but
you'd also prescribed diet or exercise
or do these sorts of things and avoid
these sorts of things so the physician
prescribes to the sick what he must do
so you know let's try not to get angry
but if you're gonna get angry
don't sit right don't fall into bad
behavior and so he says if the patient
does not submit to The Physician
The Physician does not treat him with
contempt he doesn't look down on him but
proceeding to add what advice he can by
way of persuasion again goes on with the
Cure and chrysostom says that's what
Paul is doing here he indeed who does
otherwise like a physician who's not
behaving that way aims only at
reputation and is annoyed at being
disregarded whereas the person who
really cares about the patient whether
it's Paul as a spiritual doctor or an
actual medical doctor has one single
object in view how he may restore the
patient and raise him up again how can
you fix things for the person
so how can we understand this well
chrysostom says you know it's better if
you don't get angry at all that would be
really wonderful but you're probably
going to get angry so if you do get
angry then you want to limit it in
important ways and one of these is the
sin not
but another has to do with the factor of
time and here's where we get the second
verse coming in he says
um
let not the sun go down on your wrath
would you have your fill of anger how
much do you need one hour two hours
three hours that's enough for you let
not the sun depart and leave you both at
amnity a hatred between the two of you
in conflict and he goes on and he says
well why should this be the case what's
so important about the night and here I
think you know with what's being said of
course it's assuming sort of an ancient
culture one that went on until we had
like electrical lights whenever we want
them and you know we'd have to like
rethink this in our own time perhaps
expand it also to the day he says that
the Blessed Paul dreads the night lest
overtaking in solitude him that was
wrong still burning with anger it should
again Kindle up the fire why well like
he says
as long as there are many things in the
daytime to banish it you're free to
indulge it but as soon as the evening
comes on be reconciled extinguish the
evil while it's still fresh for should
Knight overtake it the the morning will
not Avail to extinguish the further evil
that's been collected in the night we've
all probably had the experience of
waking up in the middle of the night or
not being able to get to sleep either
because of anger or some other passion
it could be anxiety it could be
excitement it could be something else
but anger has a tendency to keep us
awake and now in the The Silence of the
night without all sorts of other things
impinging on us we can ruminate we can
dwell on that anger we can allow it to
use this metaphor as we're sort of
feeding a fire that's there instead of
letting it go out putting it out before
we go to sleep
it burns through the night and in the
morning it's ready to come back up in
full Blaze and so this is why uh Paul is
telling us and Chris's thumb is
reinforcing that we want to uh before we
go to sleep or at least you know before
we settle down maybe we won't be able to
get to sleep we want to do our best to
try to banish to let go of to extinguish
that anger that enmity that hatred that
conflict with somebody else
and then here he comes to talking about
this neither give place to the devil
so
why shouldn't we give place to the devil
well because anytime we do that it's
going to be bad for us
he says to be at war with one another
that's what giving place to the devil
means and it doesn't have to be War like
shooting at each other it could be any
sort of conflict that's going on he's
got this very interesting analogy that
he provides of the devil looking for
little ways to get in there and so he
says that um
here we go just as stones in a building
as long as they're closely fitted
together and leave no interstitis no
little spot between them will stand firm
well if there's but a single needles
Passage through or a crevice no broader
than a hair this destroys and ruins all
so it is with the devil so long as we we
human beings are closely set and
compacted together he cannot introduce
one of his Wiles but when it causes us
to relax a little he rushes in like a
torrent in every case he just needs a
beginning and this is the thing which is
difficult to accomplish but this done he
makes room on all sides for himself so
you know if you're in a relationship
with people who you love and are
connected with don't let the devil get
in there in between you because he is
going to take that little space and make
it bigger and bigger and bigger until
finally there's plenty of room between
you and you're separated from each other
so you know he he also tells us that
John chrysostom that once this starts to
happen
um we're going to be at odds with each
other because we don't actually buy the
same truth he says he opens the ear to
Slanders what are Slanders you know
saying bad things about other people
right which may be actually false and
they who speak lies are the more trusted
they have enmity which plays The
Advocate not truth which judges justly
so once we start to think bad things
about people because we're in conflict
with them we are more liable to think
even more bad things about them that are
that are false when we're liable to view
these as true so he says where
friendship is even those evils which
appear which are true appear false right
we Overlook the bad things about people
so where there is enmity or hatred even
the false up here true
and this is a really interesting way of
discussing it
there's a different mind a different
tribunal which does not hear fairly but
with great bias and partiality so you
know the metaphor there is of a judgment
and when you hear bad stuff about people
who you already don't like or are angry
with or hate you're like yeah the
bastards probably are that way they
probably did do that
even though it's false he goes on and
he's got another example a balance if
lead is cast in the scale it will drag
down the hole and he says it's the same
here only that the weight of hatred or
enmity is even greater than any lead so
once again he comes back to let not the
sun go down on your anger right and he
tells us that if you don't
deal with that right away it's going to
get worse and worse and worse and the
devil is presumably involved in it he
says
if you fail to master your anger on the
very first day both on the following and
oftentimes even for a year you will be
protracting it and the hatred the enmity
will actually increase right it will
augment itself and require nothing to
Aid if you remain angry with people this
is something that gets pointed out it
transforms congeals into hatred actual
hatred which is worse than the original
anger and so how can we how can we deal
with this well
interestingly one way that chrysostom
says that we can deal with his passion
extinguish the flame reflecting on our
own sins our own failures our own
weaknesses our own places where we go
wrong how much we have to answer for to
God reflecting that we're wreaking
Vengeance not on an enemy
but on ourselves
reflecting that we are delighting the
devil so this comes back to the the
issue of don't give the devil place
we're strengthening our enemy a real
enemy and we're actually hurting
ourselves and so he says listen if you
want to be angry and revengeful and you
know involved in hatred then there's one
being that you should be directing that
at and it's not your fellow human being
and it's not God and it's not yourself
it's the devil it's okay to hate the
devil it's okay to take revenge on the
devil if you possibly can it's okay to
be angry with the devil as a matter of
fact he says it was for this purpose
that God gave us anger not that we
should thrust the sword into our own
bodies but that we should baptize the
whole blade in the devil's breast and
how do you do that well you can be angry
at the Devil but you you can't just be
angry all the time you have to reconcile
with your
fellow human beings your brothers and
sisters and thereby you push the devil
out you don't give the devil space so
you overcome anger by directing it at
the Devil and by doing the things that
are that are needed in order to end the
conflict with other people right so he
says this actually comes to pass when
we're merciful to our spiritual family
and peaceably disposed towards one
another so we you know overcome anger
through Mercy through uh pity through
compassion and we behave like decent
human beings in relation to each other
so there's all sorts of interesting
interconnected ways that chrysostom sees
anger and the devil being connected and
this this injunction about time don't
let anger linger because it's going to
create space for the devil and turn into
hatred which will eventually become very
difficult to overcome